thanks Paul for having me here tonight
I'm really excited to be here and
machine learning meetup is one of the
finest meetups we have here concerning a
data science here in New York and so
it's an honor also thank you pivotal of
course and I guess I should say thank
you to all of you for being here
I work as a data scientist why plan
since a month now and ever since I
joined I I now I know what's going on in
the city why plan is this app you put it
on your phone and they show you a short
list of curated events anything ranging
from comedy to wine tastings Broadway
shows but instead you guys decided
tonight to come and listen to me so
thank you so tonight I would like to
talk about what I've been doing in the
past five years in the form of a PhD I
completed it in January this year and
defended it later in June at this
university Tilburg in the Meadowlands
and of course I should thank my my
supervisors my daily supervisors Eric
Postma and Jack from a headache
and other work that I will presenting
here is done a little bit in the
collaboration with fair and Susan who
works in London as a data scientist who
recently got PG from Cambridge
University and allowance from Amato who
is working at Delft University in the
Netherlands so
let's get started and I should
immediately say that although the title
is outlier selection in one class
classification which was also the title
of my PhD thesis I will actually be
focusing on just the outlier selection
part so first I would like to talk about
anomalies and outliers I would like to
get you all on the same page so that we
know what we're talking about then I
want to explain the stochastic outlier
selection algorithm and after that I
want to describe to you the results that
I've done and the results from that so
what are we talking about there are many
different words that basically mean the
same thing so so first of all we have
anomaly outlier but then we also often
hear the words novelty or error or
exception and I just want to talk about
anomalies and our lives and let me give
you three examples of anomalies rotten
apple a forced painting this is our
former Queen Beatrix of the Netherlands
who is doing anomaly detection checking
to see if this painting is forged or not
and Somali pirates so I believe that a
definition is in order and it's it's a
very broad one
it goes an anomaly is an observation or
then the deviates qualitatively from
what is considered to be normal
according to a domain expert it's pretty
vague but what's important to note here
is that these are observations are in
the real world and that this is
according to a domain expert and it will
become clear when once we get to the
definition of outlier why this is
important so detecting these anomalies
is very important because they can be
expensive in case of a painting that was
actually forged or dangerous well two
examples and the one that you we had
this rotten apple not on the other hand
the Somali pirates yes both dangerous
one there's more dangerous than the
other but still oh yeah and uh nominees
can mess up your model although just
leading this anomalous data is generally
frowned upon so humans do a lot of
anomaly detection we have people at the
Coast Guard looking at big screens all
day long and they're pretty good at that
but they can also suffer from three
cognitive limitations fatigue they can
get tired after a while information
overload there may just be too many
credit card transactions going on to
keep them all loved to keep track of
them all and then there is also an
emotional buying like bias like what do
I gain from detecting something as an
anomaly or not such as again with the
force paintings so I think that a
computer is able to support the human in
this and I'll add in anomaly detection
but computers work with numbers so I
hope this doesn't come with too much of
shock so we have observations in the
real world and we should be careful to
measure the right features of these real
world observations and here we have a
visualization of these apples and apples
and oranges data set my do this if you
have this data then you're better off
using a binary classifier rather than
doing unsupervised outlier selection and
the point is here like how do you go
from real world anomalies to a
representation that the computer can
work with so again here we have an
example we have measured let's say speed
over ground and rate of turn of about a
hundred vessels and if an expert would
look at this or
look at the the real-world observations
now that this representation he or she
would say yes that's an anomaly and we
as humans look just looking at this
picture we immediately see that this is
also an outlier that's clear but there
are cases where this is not so clear and
also not immediately clear for the
algorithm so let me give you a
definition outlier and that's an outlier
is a data point that deviates quantitive
lee from what the majority of the data
points are from the majority of the data
points according to an outlier selection
algorithm so again if we contrast this
with the definition of an anomaly
first of all qualitative leap
qualitatively first is quantitatively
and outliers in in my opinion you know
after five years you you you gain a
certain opinion about this and you start
to develop a vocabulary sir just so
we're all on the same page data point if
outliers only exist in in the data world
so that's like the duality between
anomalies and outliers again pretty
vague and the exact definition differs
per algorithm so so just an example this
is this is probably one of the easiest
way to detect outliers just select any
data point which is farther away than
three standard deviations from the mean
the only thing simpler than this would
be an if statement but of course we as I
will show you we can do better than this
and we'll come across data where you
cannot use this for example not all data
is normally distributed and this also is
difficult to generalize towards higher
dimensions so let me recap like how
anomalies and outliers compare to each
other we have we have this set of
real-world observations of those if an
expert would look at these he would
label you know a certain set of
observations as a mom
and the others are than normal or
normalities and from from every
observation that's available in the real
world we of course only have a subset of
that and that's our data set so if we
take the intersection of those sets we
get a data set which has two classes the
anomalous class and the normal class and
then if you if you give this data to a
large selection algorithm and this this
algorithm comes back with
classifications then there are two
possible classifications namely outlier
and then liar and it's the it's the four
possible combinations here that are that
are interesting so we have hits false
alarms misses and correct rejections and
you can also represent this as a
confusion matrix if you're familiar with
binary classification you may have seen
this in the past so obviously we would
like to have an outlier selection
algorithm that always agrees with the
domain expert because we assume here
that the domain expert is always right
and they don't always they don't always
judge observations and data points the
same so there may be some confusion
between the two and this plays an
important role in evaluating the
algorithms and I will come to that later
let me give you an example of this here
in the top left corner we see our data
set just you know it's it's a it's
unsupervised to the algorithm but if we
again if we were to have an expert
looking at this data then he or she
would label these two points that you
see in the top right corner these are
these orange stars as anomalies so we
apply let's say a distance based outlier
selection algorithm
and we've said it such that it will
correctly classify these two anomalies
as outliers so if you already look at
the the lower right corner you will see
that these are indeed hits yes but then
there are also a lot of false alarms in
the cluster that's less dense so did
this this algorithm is is suboptimal and
we can't do better it's so this is
distance based a lot of algorithms are
or density based as I will I will show
you a couple of those but now I would
like to discuss an algorithm that's
affinity based it's the stochastic
outlier selection algorithm so so now
we've just had an introduction to
outliers and anomalies so now we're
really warmed up so let's get to the
good stuff suggesting our large
selection or SOS is enough unsupervised
outlier selection algorithm so it you
can't give it any labels or it won't do
anything with it
just give it a either feature matrix or
the similarity matrix and it employs the
concept of affinity to to represent or
to quantify the relationship between
data points and because of that it
computes outlier probabilities which in
my opinion are more insightful than just
computing unbounded a liar scores I will
also show you that later it has one
parameter which is called perplexity and
it's inspired by by TC and that I will
also explain in a moment now the the
idea behind SOS is as follows this is
more more how SOS thinks of outliers so
this is more of a specialization of that
definition of outlier that I that I gave
earlier so this is the take-home message
you don't have to write it down it will
be these slides will be put up
on an Internet so but the the idea
behind SOS is that a data point is
selected or classified as an outlier
when all the other data points have
insufficient affinity with it now I will
explain affinity don't worry but it's
what I like to say is that it was
inspired by my TC which stands for t
distributive stochastic neighbor
embedding and this is a nonlinear
nonlinear dimensionality reduction
technique developed by are we ok with
sound is there anything I can do okay
I'll just continue then developed by
Lawrence from Amata and Geoffrey Hinton
and the the goal of a dimensional as
dimensionality reduction technique is to
map a high dimensional data set onto a
lower dimensional space very often just
two dimensions or three so that we can
visually inspect it it's it's nonlinear
so it's it only cares about local
structure of the data set so the
neighborhood around each data point and
that this algorithm tries to preserve
those neighborhoods as it maps this high
dimensional data set into a lower
dimensional space so and it also uses
affinity and when I heard this so
Lawrence is a former colleague of mine
of me I felt like hey this is this is
kind of applicable to outlier selection
or it might be so I started looking into
this and yes that's what I will be
presenting tonight is that as far as I
know a stochastic a large selection is
the first a large selection algorithm
that employs the concept of affinity to
compute outlier probabilities so I've
shown you now this for long enough but
let me explain it what you see here is a
Emnes data set it contains a whole lot
of of dead digits handwritten digits
their their bitmaps let's say 20 by 20
pixels so we have grayscale values of
these so so each digit each image here
lives in a 400 dimensional space and
decent so that's that's a high
dimensional space right and how do you
how do you get insight into empty your
data set whenever you have a high
dimensional data set like you want to
know whether there's some structure some
clusters in here so you you give it to
it to tease me and it will it will map
it onto in this case a two-dimensional
space so here on the the top left corner
we will see a bunch of zeros and above
that lots of sixes so this is yeah I
really like this algorithm I want to say
that this is really my go-to algorithm
whenever I have a a new data set or
whenever I've cooked up a new
dissimilarity measure so I have borrowed
the concept of affinity and applied it
to a liar selection so let's go back to
SOS this is in a nutshell five matrices
or four matrices and vector and it goes
from you know the input matrix X then
computes a dissimilarity matrix D we
move on to an affinity matrix a binding
probability matrix is B and then we get
the outlier probabilities and a sneak
preview here is that and in the final
final vector you already see that this
the six data point is colored orange so
this might already be classified as an
outlier and this can be explained by
looking at the input matrix X so we have
a dataset containing six data points
it's just a toy data set to to explain
to you the entire algorithm six data
points and each data point has two
features and we can see that the first
feature of the sixth data point has a
higher value than the rest so eventually
by the s.res algorithm will be
classified as a as an outlier and I will
explain to you exactly how this works so
time for a demo so just to show you that
this has not been just you know research
well I just want to show you that you
can also actually use this algorithm let
me see I have it over here yes let me
let me check if everybody can see this
all right so I've got I've got a toy
data set here I've got actually the same
Manders really hard just got to trust my
yes
we've got your dos those six data points
CSV file no header and we can see that
they have two features each now we can
feed this into SOS
and we give it a perplexity of 4.5 I
will explain that what it means really
low value but that's because we don't
have a lot of data points let's see
let's see what does it do boom right
there
I'm not lying it's not just research a
beautiful law tech paper converted to a
beautiful la tech presentation though
this is this is Python code you can you
can download it it's a it's a very slow
implementation I just wanted the
implementation to be straightforward
there are lots of optimizations that
other smarter people tonight and can can
add to that but I know I will give you a
nicer demo later on which has animations
but now I have everybody's attention
again let's let's go back to the
presentation
so so this is our toy data set
represented here is in the two
dimensional space and the first step is
to convert this input matrix into this
similarity matrix and for this talk I'm
going to assume the Euclidean distance
as our dissimilarity measure but you can
use any dissimilarity measure and you
can even give as OS this similarity
matrix directly if you have a custom one
or something if you have a custom
dissimilarity matrix cooked-up so that's
that's this equation
it's the Euclidean distance and then the
next step is to still compute affinity
between data points pairwise affinities
and it's we sort of have an intuitive
understanding of what affinity means but
I would like to formalize it here as
well so affinity decreases Gaussian like
with respect to the dissimilarity
between two data points so the more
dissimilar to that data points are the
less affinity they have with each other
so and the data point has no affinity
with
itself that would be weird so here on
the on the left you can see how affinity
decreases with respect to the
dissimilarity four four three values of
Sigma this is this is the variance and
this is the corresponding equation for
that now this this variance is a scalar
that's associated with each data point
and each data point will have its own
value so let's move on to the next slide
and hopefully we'll all become clear so
the point of all this is to get smooth
neighborhoods to again if you remember
tease me is to capture the structure of
of the neighborhood around it a certain
data point now k nearest neighbor also
has neighborhoods and then you set the
value of k but they're the the property
being a neighbor is is a boolean
property and that's different from what
what SOS uses here and being neighbor is
more smooth property will become
probabilistic in a moment and the other
thing is with perplexity because that is
that is the one parameter to SOS is that
it can be any value doesn't have to be
an integer so what we want to achieve
for you you saw me setting the
perplexity to four point five is that we
want to have each neighborhood of each
data point or the neighborhood of each
data point to have the same number of
effective neighbors and this is what
perplexity can do for us I will explain
how this works at the end of one of the
explanation of SOS but all this is now
all you need to remember is that
perplexity is a measure there's a smooth
measure of the effective number of
neighbors and please note that these
these circles they they do not
correspond to boundaries but they're
just there to illustrate the variance
associated with
each data points each data point has you
can you can sort of see it as they have
a Gaussian laying on top of each other
and each Gaussian has as a certain width
and you can see here that data point six
has a much larger Gaussian that is it
needs to be much much bigger in order to
to have the same number of effective
neighbors and the fifth data point here
in the middle has a very narrow Gaussian
so those were the affinities and the
corresponding affinity matrix again you
can see that the diagonal is zero
meaning that a data point has no
affinity with itself and the next step
is to convert this to binding
probabilities and this is simply a
normal row number of a row normalization
of matrix a so we make sure that each
data point distributes there's this
binding probability to all the other
data points such that it adds up to one
so we have a binding probability
distribution associated with each data
point
now it's useful to to visualize this as
a as a graph where each vertex
corresponds to a data point so also the
locations are are the same as those in
the in the toy data set a few slides
back
and because each data point has some
binding probability to any other data
point this graph is is fully connected
but they're not uniformly distributed as
you can see because the the brightness
already or the color of these these
edges the direct these directed edges
also differ so here I have highlighted
the first data point and the the binding
probability is that it has with the
other five data points and you can see
here that these values they they add up
to 1 or 0.99 if there's a rounding issue
and and what you notice here is that it
has most the binding probabilities are
highest to the data points that are
closest to it so so there is so the
dissimilarity between these data points
is lower right the Euclidean distance
and therefore also the affinity and
therefore also well the affinity is
higher and therefore so the binding
probability is higher and the binding
probability that data point one has with
data point six is very low because it's
far away here I've highlighted data
point six how are these colors working
actually they're not they're not too bad
data point six has roughly equal binding
probabilities to the other data points
because from day two point six is
perspective all the other data points
are just far away and as you remember it
as this gaussian was pretty wide so
again let's focus on data point one but
then that the the the binding
probabilities other data points have
with it so I've now highlighted the
column of binding matrix B
yeah that looks good but then here it
becomes of course again obvious that
nobody really likes the six data point
and that's that's again the premise of
SOS I've already given it away is that
this data point will will be the outlier
in this case so very low probability to
the data point six so we have binding
probabilities next I would like to
discuss something called a stochastic
neighbor graph because because because
of these binding probabilities we can
actually construct a graph I would like
to know which data point is an outlier
and for that I want to I want to
generate a graph a stochastic neighbor
graph this is a this is a generative
process and every vertex binds to one
other vertex according to its binding
distribution right this this is
stochastic and they again they bind
independently and so the out degree is
always one the probability of a certain
graph is only depends on the edges that
are being created so just just a joint
probability of all the edges in this in
this graph and then the definition here
of being an outlier given that a certain
graph is that when nobody else has
connected to you nobody else's binds to
your of in other words selects you as as
a neighbor right so let's generate a
couple of stochastic neighbor graphs
here we have three let's start with the
top one graph a and here we have yeah if
we if we ask every data point to to bind
to its well it let's let's say its
nearest neighbor or
with the data point it has the highest
binding probability with we get this
graph so this is this is the most
probable graph on the on the right you
will see the probability of generating
this graph and given this graph data
points 1 4 & 6 are in the outlier class
because there's no other data point
binding to them no data point selects
them as outlier so with the next graph
that's already a little bit less
probable and if we look at the the third
graph where most of the data points
select data point 6 well you can also
look at that the probability of
generating this graph and we see that
it's very improbable it is definitely
possible but very improbable and and
here we have data points 1 & 3 in the
outlier class so being in the outlier
class is deterministic but generating
this stochastic neighbor graph is like
it says stochastic so we don't want to
know just for one graph which data
points are outliers we want to know it
as taking taking all graphs in
consideration we want to know a
probability of this data point belonging
to the outlier class so so because there
is a probability distribution or because
there is a probability so you associated
with each graph you can generate there
is a discrete probability distribution
associated with the set of all graphs
which you see here on the Left we have
the discrete probability mass and the
three graphs you saw before are here
marked indeed graph a is very probable
where it's the most probable in this
case and I've also plotted this for
three different values of perplexity you
see that it's pretty sensitive here
because we don't have that many many
data points in the in the toy data set
but as you increase the perplexity you
will actually
it will become too smooth so I will show
you also later that setting this
perplexity parameter will can be
compared to the sensitivity of the
algorithm so we can approximate the
outlier probability for each data point
by by sampling these graphs right we can
just we have this stochastic process we
can just we can just generate well a lot
of graphs infinitely many if we do that
then we actually approximate the outlier
probabilities and this this equation at
the bottom here it's just a matter of
counting so so we generate a graph and
we we we check whether a data point is
is in the outlier class so that's in the
in the brackets here and then we we
typecast is this boolean to to an
integer by using this indicator random
variable here and we just keep counting
and we divide it with the number of
graphs we generated so so in this figure
you can see how we slowly converge to
the outlier probabilities of these data
points it takes quite a while these are
a million iterations it's on it's on a
log scale and you can indeed see that
data point six has the highest outlier
probability in this case all right this
is generating a million graphs and that
yeah that's not a good thing so it's
time for another demo because I'm
getting kind of tired with all this all
this let me see oh I am here d3 alright
so so this is a data set I found
recently I saw in hacker news someone
applying multi-dimensional scaling
another dimensionality reduction
technique to voting data
of the Senate so we have here the
Democrats and Republicans blue and red
and we have a couple of independent
senators let's see and on the right you
have them listed not all of them it's
too much is it text okay it's right yeah
and the mapping so this is so so we have
here 103 senators and so far they have
done 172 votes so we have a data set
that has 103 data points living in 172
dimensional space and TCE once again has
map this onto a lower dimensional space
it's not the best algorithm for
visualizing outliers so you will see
that the a liar values here computed by
SOS do not directly correspond with what
yeah what you would think as visual
outliers and here because technical
detail is that tes nee symmetrize is the
affinity between two data points so if
there is a an outlier which with which
nobody has any any affinity it will
still be about half of those two data
points combined because the outlier has
affinity with the other data points so
they will always you know this this
algorithm says to them you know come and
join the group so you will always end up
with the clusters but we have some we
have some outliers here at the bottom so
like I said we have the names on the
right the states and some bars let me
let me generate one stochastic neighbor
graph yeah I should say I'm very proud
of this I I hacked this in in
CoffeeScript in d3 which is really cool
and I now we have one such stochastic
neighbor graph lots of error
lots of directed edges here and some
senators here have an outlier
probability or
our frequency of one that's because
we've only generated one suggest America
and like I said we want to generate a
lot so that we approximate the ally
probability so so I can I can play this
and we keep on generating stochastic
neighbor graphs and as you see these
values on the right they change
let me fresh that yes we've got some
outliers already on the top they're
still fluctuating a lot as you may
remember from the figure earlier that it
takes time for these values to converge
let's see who are our most common
senators I know nothing of politics in
your country but I hope you guys are
enjoying this doesn't make sense to you
when I when I do like this you go oh
yeah yeah okay sorry yes oh I should
have explained that that represents the
outlier probability when the bar is
entirely full that means that they have
an outlier probability of one and when
its width of zero pixels they have an
outlier probability of zero they do they
do this is just a visualization for us
to see what's going on like internally
no that's correct
so the higher probabilities are computed
in the original space the hundred and
seventy two dimensional space and this
was just for us - well for me to give
you a nice demo but again it's not the
the best representation because tease me
and you know those affinities that are
symmetrized so I hope this somewhat
clarifies what I've been explaining for
the past few minutes you know all these
these dry equations and graphs now we at
least have an animation so I hope that
everybody well that we're all now again
the same page and if not yeah oh yes um
man I all this interactivity and so if I
hover oh yes oh here and it is really
tough oh yeah let's see which which oh
yeah yeah yeah you see them you see the
data point that the circle which has a
black border and we out of which come
arrows let me stop it for a moment this
is crazy you see here that it indeed it
has an out degree of 1 as we say it
selects one other data point as its
neighbor and we can also have a look
into which other data points it selects
and that's how much let me go over here
oh yeah well of course I would have to
do it upside down go to here we see if I
if I hover over these data points you
will see that a lot of that there are
multiple arrows often going to this data
point so these are data points that
select this there's this other data
point I don't know who's there Portman
so that's why he indeed has a very low
outlier probability because he is being
selected here let me play it again you
can see yeah it has a lot of arrows most
of the time if we then just for
completeness go back here this one and
we can wait a long time for this data
point to be selected right you guys get
the picture
animation good
stop it and go back back to some
equations all right
so like I said it and like you've seen
it takes a very long time to converge to
this out to t2 these outlier
probabilities but we need a little bit
smarter than this and we can compute the
outlier probabilities exactly by
marginalizing out graph stochastic
neighbor graph G and so we compute the
marginal probability so to speak again
some counting happens here between the
brackets and this this indicator
variable that you see here the
connection point oh yes
and we need to take the probability of
this graph into a complication not each
graph is equally probable so instead of
generating a million stochastic neighbor
graphs we can we only need to iterate
over about 15,000 graphs but this
explodes very quickly if we have 10 data
points is that correct
some yeah let me say that if you have a
data set which has a thousand data
points then you already have three point
seven times ten to the 199 possible
graphs so this is this is computational
conversationally intractable but of
course there is a solution to this
problem and that's we can compute the
outlier probabilities in closed form if
we only think again about the intuition
between stochastic analyzed selection
and that's that a data point is selected
as as outlier when the other data points
have no affinity with it so in slightly
different words we could say that given
these binding probabilities that we have
right bij the binding probability or the
probability that data point I binds to
data point J right given those we we can
say that it's the joint probability that
data point I is never chosen as a
neighbor by the other data points so all
we have to do is is invert our binding
probabilities and multiply them together
so if we go to if you if you look at the
the numpad you see it's just multiplying
the columns in this in this binding
matrix inverted that is so if you don't
believe me here is your some proof I'm
not gonna walk through it it was just
nice to do this it's in it's in the
paper in that in the technical report or
or my thesis if if you're interested so
yeah we can actually compute this in
closed form so so why did I show you all
these these graphs and you know it's I
guess I guess I really wanted to have
this accepted somewhere I don't know you
you want to have some formalism right
and it was parents whose off who
actually came up with
putting this into a graph theoretical
framework so that we actually you know
what we're doing is right it's not just
some some random thing we're computing
here so well just to finish it off if
you want to select outliers and rather
have classifications than outlier
probabilities you just you can just put
it a threshold on this and this dashed
red line that you see here is the
decision boundary so every every data
point that's inside it is an in liar and
outside of this is classified as an
outlier so and this is also possible in
the Python implementation of course so
what I haven't explained yet is is this
perplexity a thing how do we actually
set those those variances of those six
data points right you remember that it
has something to do with the effective
number of neighbors and perplexity is
actually a statistic associated with a
probability distribution that comes from
information theory and it's there's
nothing magic about it there is just
defined as follows is to do the power of
the Shannon entropy of the binding
probabilities I didn't come up with this
this was also used in MTV but what I can
tell you is that if you is that if you
look at the actual H closest neighbors
so H could be five just as again think
about K nearest neighbor if you think
about if you if you look at the five
closest data points with respect to one
other data point and you add up the
binding probabilities that this data
point has with these five then they're
more or less 0.9 so I hope that somewhat
explains why they like it what we can
call this the effective number of
neighbors and what you see here is
well six six lines so like I said every
data point has a different variance
associated because they all have a
different neighborhood and so they all
need a different variance to get the
same perplexity four point five in this
case we find this value so the variance
that yields the correct perplexity with
a simple continuous binary search so in
the top so we try out we find the
variance and we continuously look up the
the very perplexity that that
corresponds to this and you can see it
converges pretty quickly and perplexity
again influences the outlier
probabilities if you set it too high
everybody will sort of have the same
binding probability so they will all be
regarded the same and if you if you set
it too low then you will be you will end
up with with an algorithm that's quite
sensitive so a lot of our liars and it's
it's in reality whatever that is if you
if you if you apply this to a to real
data sets you will never have something
this sensitive this is only because
we're using six data points so on to
some experiments some results because we
have this algorithm how do we actually
know whether how well this is performing
so the first thing I did is to to get
some understanding of how SOS behaves
and how it compares two to four other
outlier selection algorithms my apology
my apologies for the labels you have to
tilt your head I didn't want to redo
this this figure was too much work again
we have three data sets three different
tied at assets' I called banana that's
the top row densities which contains two
different clusters of which one is a
lobbed answer and
other and a ring I hope you can see the
white dots in here they represent the
data points in these three data sets so
in each column we have the same three
data sets and the other algorithms are
starting at the left its least square
outlier detection elessedil or the local
correlation integral don't worry if
you've never heard of them it's that's
low key then we have the local outlier
factor this is actually a pretty famous
one Orloff and then there's a K nearest
neighbor rhythm and on the on the in the
right column we have SOS so I've just
applied these algorithms to these to
these data sets and I have no you get
these these outliers core plots or these
heat maps by adding ballad by letting
each each pixel so to speak beat an
extra data point applying the so make it
part of the data set compute its outlier
probability and give it a color right so
so red dark red here corresponds to one
more actually the highest probability or
score that we encounter here and they go
all the way down to blue which means a
very low outlier probability so so just
looking at these plots we can say
something about how these these
algorithms behave right it's just in two
dimensions but still we can see for
example in the in the left column in the
middle we can see that
LSO D just makes these these two circles
they're roughly equal size and this is
very different from from the other
algorithms or loci so the second column
middle row doing weird we're very weird
moon shapes loft in the middle middle
row you see it has this very it has it
almost has this kind of boundary like
when you when you as an extra data point
right as a if you move a little bit too
much you you got a totally different
outlier probability so the the somehow
says how how well an outlier selection
algorithm is is able to capture that
this data set and I should also mention
that the the a liar score is produced by
these four other algorithms are
unbounded so that means that if we look
and say either loft so that so the
middle column or the fourth column you
will see that these these these collars
are ever-changing that means that the
outlier score is ever increasing so the
further you move away from the other
data points the higher your outlier
score will be in my opinion it's it's
more it's more intuitive to have the
probability because you will then have
sort of a context you know that that
zero is the lowest possible value and
one is the highest possible with but
with these scores a domain expert for
example if you ever want to report these
values he or she might have difficulty
interpreting these three scores so this
was more of a qualitative evaluation of
these these five algorithms now to move
on to something that's a little bit more
quantitative we need data we need we
need data sets and it's hard to find
these outlier data sets where we have
labels where outlier or data points are
labeled either as as normality or
anomaly so what I do is I just take a
standard multi class they just said may
have two or more classes such as here
the lovely iris flower dataset you've
probably heard of it which has three
classes
and we can convert these into three one
class datasets where by just relabeling
the data points we get we end up with a
data set which has both anomalies and
normalities and we let each class be the
normal class in each of those data sets
well then we applied the outlier
selection algorithms today and we get an
area under the curve score and we
combine that by by weighting these
individual area under the curve values
because if you have one class that's
that's very well represented and others
is and the other class is not you may
end up with skewed values so that's why
it's weighted so we applied the outlier
selection algorithm as follows because
if we have these two classes as you as
you see here in the bottom there really
not any any outliers in there so we need
to somehow simulate that there are
anomalies in this data set so what we do
is we keep the entire normal class in
here and we we compute the allies scores
of those data points and we add one
anomalous data point rerun the algorithm
and store the outlier probability
computed for death anomaly and we do
this for all anomalies so this is only
for evaluation right it's it's a very
very slow process but this is just to to
get a sense like how would this
algorithm classify this other data point
which is labeled as an anomaly so again
area under the curve here on the Left we
see both how the the data points were
labeled by the domain expert right so
the ones that are in the anomalous class
are on the left side of the of the gray
dashed line and you know the normalities
are on
right side and then this this red dashed
line separates is again if you remember
this decision boundary around your your
normal class so anything that's outside
of it is classified as outlier anything
inside it is as it's classified as an in
liar and then of course we can have we
can have disagreements between the
algorithm and and and the domain expert
so we end up with hits false alarms
misses and correct rejects if we change
the threshold which is here set to 0.57
if we if we change this from the lowest
possible value to the highest possible
possible value so we integrate over that
we actually end up with the this curve
over here the ROC curve and we we take
the area under this curve to come up
with the area under curve right it all
makes sense and again we combine for for
all of the one class data sets we
combine this into one value so what you
see here are 18 real world data sets
these well except two of them they all
come from the UCI machine learning
repository so these are fairly common
data sets nothing too spectacular but
what you can see here is the weighted
area under the curve on the y-axis and
the Purple Line that's say the size OS
so and higher means better so I actually
forgot how often it's it's performing
well it's not performing best a couple
of times but even then it's it's at
least eighty percent of what the of what
the best algorithm had as a you see so
this is pretty good right and while
real-world datasets really give us a
good idea of how our algorithm would
perform in the real world it it's it's
useful to use synthetic data sets
data sets that we can control with a
parameter because that may give us
additional insight into how the
algorithm behaves when we when we slowly
change some of the data properties such
as overlap or varying densities or just
cardinalities and I've come up with
seven of those data sets they all have a
one parameter which we will slowly
change that means that we we generate
one synthetic data set for each lambda
value here we see a visual
representation of those seven data sets
and let's focus on the fifth column
so that's see we see two clusters here
two Gaussian clusters and they start off
as being far apart but as lambda
decreases in this case which is the
distance between these two clusters we
see that these clusters start to overlap
and then finally and until they are
completely overlapping and what we want
to find out is that how how does this
affect the performance of our outlier
selection algorithms and so that's one
example but you can see also here that
in synthetic data set D the cardinality
of the of the ring of the second ring
slowly decreases and we have data set a
all the way to the right we have this
ring that is that's getting smaller and
smaller again this is this is overlap
but and slightly different so let's see
what this means so now we we again have
the area under the curve on the y axis
and lambda the XX x axis so as we slowly
decrease or increase depending on the
data set this value we see that the
performance of these algorithms change
for example for a well they all go down
but the performance all goes goes down
but for SOS it goes down well at a later
stage
so again higher is better you actually
have the legend so there are some weird
things going on I don't have time to
discuss this right now but especially
data set G is quite surprising and that
all the algorithms are all the other
four algorithms are affected pretty much
by this but as data set this was data
said gee I don't even know yeah you know
this is not particularly what you will
see in a real world but well at least
it's something we can use to gain
insight so so I'm Arianna the curve some
some performance measures and the final
trick is of course to see whether these
performance differences are actually
significantly different and here I have
used the the so called
post hoc nemenyi test which all what it
does it first ranks the algorithms per
data set so every every every element
per data set so every algorithm the best
performing one gets ranked of one and
the next one ranked of two or three ties
you know that's taken care of and what
it does is what you see here and this
critical difference diagram is the the
average rank of each algorithm so the
arrow points and the top diagram
corresponds to the real world data sets
the bottom one to the synthetic data
sets and a lower number here means it
means it means better and you can see
that SOS has a very low average rank and
this is actually significantly different
from the rest because these algorithms
are not connected by a horizontal bar
for p is 0.05 and for for algorithms
that are connected by a horizontal bar
that means that their performance is not
significant
different so wow that was a lot let me
let me finish this presentation by it
gets by giving you a conclusion and
that's well I've told you a little bit
about outliers and anomalies and I've
presented to you outlier well the
stochastic outlier selection algorithm
and my thesis actually so I go a little
bit deeper into this but the the answer
to my problem statement is that in the
outlier selection can support human
anomaly detection and as OS as presented
here I think it's a pretty intuitive
algorithm I hope I have been able to
explain it to you and it's a
probabilistic algorithm to to select our
lives it is performing really well but
of course it's important to keep in mind
that there is all that there is that you
think all too no free lunch theorem and
that says that there is no single best
algorithm right for every algorithm you
can find a data set on which it will
perform less than some other algorithm
so there is no machine learning
algorithm out there that can solve all
our problems and well that's the caveat
here so I've been showing you lots of
nice results but I am this is actually
Chapter five and six I am very well
aware that a stochastic a large
selection is not the best our rhythm out
there for all data sets but who knows it
may be useful for you the code there at
there is code available there's a
there's a Python implementation if I
have some time I may even you know make
it compatible with the scikit-learn or
poured it over to some some other faster
language but I won't
I suggest you you check it out if you're
interested and that's about it that's
what I had to say thank you all for
listening and if there are any questions
please ask them thank you
alright sorry the biggest data set
yes so that this goes into the thousands
so fairly small data sets no big data
but and that's because in its current
form the complexity of SOS is N squared
and this is I think it's mostly to do
with the distances it computes between
your data points now there are all sorts
of fancy tricks you can apply to
approximate this so so even the the TC
algorithm has already come out with
certain improvements there is something
called the barns Hut the t's me where it
uses random projections so that your
your your nearest neighbor search is
first of all much faster and I'm sure
you can apply the same optimization
tricks to SOS but I haven't looked into
that that was not you know the focus I
would love for as it has to be somewhat
faster yeah so in the thousands all
right we seek
Oh
registers
yes so if so if I understand the
question correctly what is the influence
of the dissimilarity measure the
affinity function yes so so that
actually makes sure that if so where the
Euclidean distance is linear the
affinity will make sure that you you
sort of have a neighbor who you will
sort of confine within this region you
will not
there's no the binding distribution
doesn't decrease linearly with as data
points become more or less similar to
you so that things will stay local so
and then of course the affinity is again
influenced by by the perplexity so the
effective number of neighbors and this
definitely has as an influence like I
said on the only outlier probabilities
yeah you could try it I I've never tried
any other because I've yeah like I said
as well as has been inspired by by TC
and they use exactly the same equation
yeah if question over here
oh definitely a few if you go on to the
meetup page in the for this particular
evening you'll see a link to my my
github account or actually directly to
the SOS repository yeah
yes well they are not they're not
symmetric so the question is our
affinities symmetric so with Disney they
are that's sort of you know to make sure
that outliers will join the larger
clusters so that you will have a nice
visualization but for for SOS it would
actually you know it would it would make
the algorithm I'll sort of worthless
because you want to have to detect data
points as outliers you want to have you
want to be able that they get less
affinity from the other data points but
still and I can go here you will see
that for example data point six has a
point three binding probability rights
and this this is actually the affinity
but then normalized and I should have
picked but then if we look at
sorry one yes one in six that's better
so one only has probably the probability
of 0.04 to to bind to six but the
reverse is that that vertex six here has
a probability of 0.1 - to bind to vertex
one yes so they're they're not symmetric
I saw that hand a while ago
no you would actually have to recompute
it everything you can I'm sure there are
certain approximations that you can do
for example if I've been playing around
with turning this into a one class
classifier which is basically a semi
supervised version of this where where
you build a model of your normal class
and then all the other data points are
just well you don't have to recompute
all the different variances for these
data points and as you get new data
points you can very fast very quickly
classify these new data points but it's
it's an approximation and but like I
said there are many many approximations
possible yeah
say buying points are there any
situations apply the places
yeah okay so the question is can we
construct the data set on which there is
which the other algorithms will perform
better and yes again the the no free
lunch theorem I would think that yet no
I don't actually I
I've not come across well I've not come
up with a synthetic data set myself
because I've got all to the best of my
knowledge I've not really seen this
before
David ah has done this I think in 92 in
some form with changing the number of
data points but yeah no no but you you
you can download the code and and create
create artificial data sets to check it
out Thanks
if I have a dataset which is a simple
line and as so we for example to a
ransack Saria what yeah
the best line to the dataset the
averages robot against those outliers
yeah
it's about these these these data points
yeah so
SOS doesn't really have any notion of
the line it works on distances but then
again if you notice of your data then
you might be better off no applying PCA
to it and getting a normal distribution
to it or so it also depends on what do
you know as a domain expert about about
your data set yeah
yeah yes so the question is are all
algorithms algorithms unsupervised and
the answer is yes
mmm-hmm if I compare data less with semi
supervisor supervisor algorithms no not
not SOS in this form I have because that
wouldn't be fair in my opinion and you
do need label data to be able to to
evaluate the performance of your of your
algorithms but I have compared the one
class classifier version of SOS with
other one class classifiers that's
chapter five and six of the phases but
in my opinion yeah you shouldn't be
comparing unsupervised with supervisor
rhythms
yes because what it does is it simply
computes the Euclidean distance or any
other distance measure that you were
given and that's supported inside PI or
you can even give it a dissimilarity
matrix a yourself and there's a
parameter for that so yeah we have time
for one more question
there hey
no we only have time for one
I acted an anomaly right there yeah yeah
yeah yeah well definitely but Sigma
square of what okay so the question is
can we use Sigma square instead of
perplexity yes but what we would like to
achieve is that every data point has the
same number of effective neighbors so to
accomplish that they all need a
different variance you can you can
actually you can you can set the same
variance for all data points but then
you you do not take the the local
density of the data set into account
it's not adaptive okay that's the time
we have I guess thank you very much
again